hello hi happy birthday uncle Hank
you're not gonna say that he's just
gonna say hi
good morning Hank it's Thursday May 5th
2011 you are 31 years old it's Hank Oh
DeMayo so Hank in the video responses
below you'll find many amazing birthday
wishes from nerdfighteria I'll be
tweeting and reblogging those all day
also for your birthday I thought Henry
your name and today you will also be
receiving a large box full of birthday
greetings from nerdfighters all over the
world that were mailed to a peel box in
Ohio that p.o box is maintained by the
nerd fight a stick Valerie 27 76 to
2,776 Valerie to enter the Internet put
the first in our hearts Hank in a few of
those cards we'll find a dollar or two
we would like to challenge you to pool
that money and spend it in the way that
in your opinion most increases awesome
so we look forward to seeing what you do
with that and then friend if you still
wanna send Hank a belated birthday card
that is possible just mail it to the PIO
box in the doobly-doo
and lastly Hank as previously noted it
is Thursday I chose not to upload a
video yesterday because I figured that
the greatest gift I can give my brother
is the opportunity to force me to do
something humiliating and/or
embarrassing and or unpalatable so
nerdfighters leave your punishment
suggestions in comments and Hank when
you are choosing a punishment I ask only
that you not think of the brother who
tried to poison you to death with iodine
when you were an infant or the brother
who repeatedly stole from your piggy
bank when you were a child but the
brother with whom you have been making
YouTube videos lo these many years
all right maybe you're 31 today since
you turned 30 you have continued to
publish eco geek org the best
environmental technology website on the
internet and you fostered the career of
young musicians from chameleon circuit
to Mike Lombardo through your work at
dftba records in the last year you also
organized and ran VidCon the largest
online video conference in the world
frustrated with the increasing
three-dimensionality of the screens we
look at precisely so we can avoid
looking at the actual three-dimensional
world you invented 2d glasses you also
oversaw the 2010 project for awesome
which raised more than $150,000 for
charity and you wrote songs about making
babies and Phineas Gage and the
fundamental constituent of matter
observed in 1968 through deep electric
scatter in the last year you made more
than 100 videos that we watch more than
10 million times you inspired us to
support the building of a well by
traveling to Haiti with water.org you
created your
pants more or less overnight things they
don't make sense new viewers and you
bill fototrama ton at the hate games
YouTube channel and you ran through
there fail and you donated blood twice
and two days ago you beat portal 2 Hank
that's a good year and while I know
you'd hasten to say that none of this
could be done without nerdfighteria and
that's true
just like you need us we need you so
thank you and Hank not to quote a quote
I stole from my wife and used in my
first novel but while I understand that
imagining the future is a kind of
nostalgia
I still can't wait to see what you do
with 31 Hank thank you for being awesome
best wishes happy Hank Oh DeMaio I will
see you tomorrow is something I haven't
been able to say in a long time
[Music]